>> THIS WEEK WE'VE SEEN TWO MORE
EXAMPLES OF ABUT HOW BIG TECH
AND OTHER BIG CORPORATIONS ARE
CATERING TO THE POLITICAL LEFT
AT EVERY TURN.
I REMEMBER ON MONDAY WE TOLD YOU
ABOUT HOW QUICKLY CREDIT CARD
COMPANIES FELL IN LINE OF A
DEMOCRATS LOBBIED THAT THEY
TRACK GUP PURSES SEPARATELY.
SPEAKING OF TRACKING, THIS WEEK
AT MULTIPLE SENATE HEARINGS WE
LEARN THAT TWITTER HAS THE
CAPABILITY NOT ONLY TO TRACK
INDIVIDUAL USERS.
USER DATA, GEO LOCATIONS, AND
TWITTER USERS.
IS THAT ACCURATE.
>> I WAS THE HEAD OF ENGINEERING
FOR THE WHOLE COMPANY.
>> DID YOU HAVE ACCESS TO USER
DATA?
I'M LOOKING FOR A YES OR A NO.
>> I THINK I COULD HAVE GOTTEN
IT.
>> IF YOU CAN GET IT, THAT'S
WHAT WE CALL ACCESS.
YO DID HAVE ACCESS TO USER DATA
IS THAT IS THAT A YES?
>> YEAH -- THAT'S PROBABLY
RIGHT.
>> THAT WAS DEVASTATING JOINING
ME NOW, A MAN YOU JUST SAW
MISSOURI SENATOR JOSH HOLLY.
SENATOR, WHAT WERE THESE
ENGINEERS DOING WITH THIS DATA,
AND WHY DID IT TAKE YOU ABOUT
FOUR QUESTIONS TO GET HIM TO SAY
THE OBVIOUS.
HERE'S THE REALLY CHILLY THING,
A WHISTLE BLOWER TOLD ME UNDER
OATH THAT HE BELIEVES THAT
TWITTER ENGINEERS HAVE DOXX,ED
USERS BEFORE.
HE THINKS THAT IT'S VERY
POSSIBLE THAT TWITTER ENGINEERS
HAVE GOTTEN INTO PEOPLE'S
ACCOUNT AND ALTERED STUFF IN THE
ACCOUNT, RECORD OF TWEETS, MAYBE
EVEN TWEETED OUT UNDER YOUR
NAME, UNDER THE USER'S NAME.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY UNBELIEVABLE.
WE'RE KNOW THAT THESE COMPANIES
OUR FARR LEFT COMPANIES THE
EMPLOYEES WITH OVERWHELMINGLY
LEFTEST AND HERE WE HAVE
REAL-WORLD PROOF THAT LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF LEFT WING TWITTER
EMPLOYEES CAN HACK ACCOUNT AND
DO WHATEVER THEY WANT.
YO REFERENCE THAD THAT TERM
WHISTLE BLOWER HERE'S SOMETHING
ELSE HE SAID DURING THE
TESTIMONY THAT WAS EARLIER THIS
WEEK.
>> THE CORPORATE SECURITY,
FICTIONAL SECURE SECURITY TEAM
HAD BEEN CONTACTED AND TOLD
THERE WAS AT LEAST ONE AGENT OF
THE MSS ONE OF CHINAA'S
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE ON THE PAY
RELEASING INSIDE TWITTER.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DETECT
THEM, IT IS VERY VALUABLE AS A
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE COMPANY AND
MOWS LIKELY NOT DOING YOUR JOB.
>> SENATOR, WHAT ARE THE CHANCES
RIGHT NOW THAT CHINA IS
OPERATING IN SOME CAPACITY
WITHIN THE SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES INCLUDING TWITTER?
>> VERY HIGH.
I MEAN, IT SOUNDS LEAKAL MOST A
HUNDRED% BASED ON WHAT THE
WHISTLE BLOWER TESTIFIED TO.
AND YOU KNOW LISTEN, I MEAN
THERE'S A REASON THEY WANT TO
GET ACCESS Y.
BECAUSE THE DATA IS SO EASY TO
GET AMERICANS PERSONAL
INFORMATION, BUT HERE'S THE
THING I'M WORRIED ABUT, OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT, OUR OWN GOVEM, WANTS
TO CONTROL THESE COMPANIES AND
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE TO ASK VERY
HARD THE COMPANIES ARE WELLING
TO TURN OVER THE KEYS OF THE
KINGDOM TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WHO WAS FIRST ON
THE LIST FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO GO TO TO TALK
ABOUT SENSORSHIP WITH THEIR
UNCONSTITUTIONAL DES INFORMATION
BOARD, TWITTER.
FIRST ON THE LIST.
WHO ARE WE GOING TO GO MEET
WITH?
TWITTER.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT FACEBOOK SAT
DOWN WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAT TOOK DOWN
ACOUNCIL BASED ON WHAT BIDEN'S
TEAM WAS TELLING THEM TO DO.
CAN WE TAKE THIS ACCOUNT DOWN,
AND FACEBOOK SAYS YES, WE CAN WE
1R-9 WE HAVE THE EMAILS FOR IT.
THEE THESE ARE SENSORSHIP
MACHINES AND THEY'RE BEING
MANIPULATED EVERY WHICH WAY.
>> THEY'RE PROXIES SENSORS FOR
THE GOVEM.
WHICH IS WHY WHEN YOU GET POWER
BACK AND WE HOPE THAT'S VERY
SOON, RATHER THAN A LOT OF ALL
OF US YOU KNOW PUTTING OUT OUR
HOT AIR ON THIS, ACTUALLY
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE,
SENATOR, AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK
THE PEOPLE ARE EXPECT WHACK YOU
ALL SAY POWER I KNOW YOU AGREE
WITH THAT.
SPEAKING OF SOMETHING YOU JUST
SAID TICK TALK TIK-TOK COO
TESTIFIED ON THE HILL AND MADE
AN ADMISSION ABOUT SOME OF THE
EMPLOYEE'S LOCATIONS.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE DO HAVE EMPLOYEES BASED IN
CHINA.
WE ALSO HAVE VERY STRICT ACCESS
CONTROLS AROUND THE TIPOFF DATA
THAT THEY CAN ACCESS, AND WHERE
DATA IS STORED, WHICH IS HERE EN
THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE'VE ALSO SAID UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD WE GIVE THAT
DATA TO CHINA.
OUR FINAL AGREEMENT WITH THE US
GOVERNMENT WILL SATISFY ALL
NATIONAL SECURITY CONCERNS.
>> SENATOR, A LOT OF PEOPLE
BREATH WAS TAKEN AWAY BAY THAT
ADMISSION.  WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS.
THEY WERE ALL GOING TO BE
SEPARATE, TIK-TOK, SEPARATE
OWNERSHIP, WE DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT CHINA.
MIKE POMPEO DISAGREES.
>> I TOTALLY DISAGREE.
HERE'S THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER.
TIK-TOK HAS CHINESE EMPLOYEE
WHOSE HAVE ACCESS TO US USER
DATA, AND THEY'RE DOING NOTHING
TO STOP IT, AND BY THE WAY, THEY
EMPLOY MEMBERS OF THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY WHO HAVE ACCESS
TO USER DATA.
THE WITNESS TESTIFIED UNDER OATH
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS TALKING ABOUT
TIK-TOK, TWITTER OR FACEBOOK,
YOU CAN BE SURE IF YOU'RE ON
THOSE SERVICES YOUR INFORMATION
IS PROBABLY GETTING REVIEWED BY
SOME FOREIGN GOVERNMENT AND IS
ALSO PROBABLY GOAL GETTING
REVIEWED BY THIS GIVEEM, BY THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT, AND WHENNER THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANTS THEM
TO SENSOR THEY'RE GOING TO,
WHENEVER CHINA WANS TO GET HOLD
OF YOUR DATA, THEY CAN.
>> SENATOR; THANK YOU